the president actually had to issue an
apology just a couple days ago he had to
apologize to Kamala Harris who is the
California Attorney General and he well
he called her the quote the best-looking
Attorney General and then women's groups
were up in arms because you know this is
sexualizing her and they worked so hard
to gain equality etcetera etcetera I
feel I must start with women here to me
this seems a little uh there's something
a little disingenuous about this because
everyone wants to be appreciated for how
they look if they look good you want to
get credit for that he said you look
good he didn't say oh that dumpy woman
over you know dance so I take it away I
love this topic um and you know I just
so you guys know the full context um he
prefaced it by basically telling her how
incredibly accomplished strong
intelligent she is he said everyone in
the room has has to watch out for her
because she's so great this and that I
got it all here I just didn't want to
focus yeah yeah yeah no but I think that
it's important to put it in context
because had he just said hey everyone
Kamala Harris she's super hot like let's
give her a round of applause like that's
different that's been littling her
accomplishments but in that case he
basically called her the full package
like she's intelligent she's
accomplishes everything you could
possibly want and she's attractive and
honestly if someone it said that to me
if the President of the United States it
said that to me I would lose it like in
a good way
like movie like good lose it like I
would be so unbelievably flattered so I
get it I get that feminists don't want
uh women didn't bill the accomplishments
of women to be belittle but I don't
think that's what he was doing here yeah
and also they've now shown many clips
where he's given awards to men where he
says oh this is the best-looking guy in
the room or look how handsome he is or
he's awful tall look at his hair what do
you think first of all that was that was
a great breakdown and you are beautiful
when you break something
I'm gonna break it things down um you
know it's really I took I get that you
don't want to sexualize a woman
especially you know in that kind of
setting yeah and you don't want to but
you know at the same time you can't take
the boy out of the thing and the thing
out of the boy right so he's still gonna
be a human being and she is attractive
and it's like so we have to pretend that
isn't going on I don't know it's I'm not
a woman and it's tougher in the
workplace for a woman that is for a man
so I don't really know what to say about
it but all I can oh is that it it makes
men it's that that's when you get that
remember they would just talk about the
white guy backlash right that's like so
now I can't even tell a woman she's
pretty guarded what is this Russia we
loot you know so that's it get to that
kind of thing stirring up in man I'm
saying something nice and I'm getting in
trouble for sinks there's nothing I can
do so it starts to make certain men feel
like they're damned if they do and
they're damned if they don't yeah yeah
and and so an interesting thing has
happened in society that I had not like
too happy about and and I know that a
lot of women are comfortable with this
they would have prefer to have it this
way but sometimes I like getting a
compliment about the way I look for my
male peers you know and I wouldn't be
offended by it but a lot of women out
there would be offended by it so like
sometimes when I put extra effort like
I'm like you know what I'm gonna really
really focus on the blush today or
whatever it is yeah I like I like it
when someone notices and says like hey I
noticed your haircut but it's crazy
because we created an environment now
where guys are afraid to tell women that
they're attractive and I I don't think
that that was what the goal was in the
beginning the goal was to prevent sexual
harassment for guys like grabbing you
and saying things that were degrading to
you yeah how much of this do you think
is just because we have these advocacy
groups you know there's women's advocacy
groups there's you know glad for gazers
PETA all this stuff where they just
they're in the business of having to
wrangle feathers otherwise they're out
of business I mean it really is a money
thing for them to they she they sort of
had to say something about this because
this is their bread and butter kind of
ironic that Peter was ruffling feathers
that's feather but even on Rush Limbaugh
says it's the gay mafia who's earning
and you know the gay mafia oh yeah they
make you an offer you can't refuse
because it's so fabulous
they give you the kiss of death they use
tongue and a reach-around come on I know
I've got jokes ready we got a rimshot
thank you bro hey watch the Mon look
write it this is a clean show clean show
all right well I think we I think we
yeah you're that one up though yeah so
uh it didn't but that again it that's
another you kind of you get to backlash
against the good thing you're trying to
do and then it gets bad gets turned into
a negative thing which is weird yeah do
you think we just live in this overly
apologetic society knits a crazy at the
president I know he just sort of he
didn't have to apologize here but he did
he just came out did it immediately just
to end this thing but it's sad that we
don't you think that that diminishes
when there really is yes sex sexual
harassment I think it diminishes that
think that's that's like so now when
someone is actually aggrieved or
somebody does something wrong now it's
gonna be kind of in a gray area because
well he just said she was pretty is it
one of those things yeah and the irony I
think in this particular case with Obama
we've never had a president and a first
lady who so much of their images but it
really is based on how they look she's
beautiful they're always seen in perfect
clothes perfectly smiling you know they
have their own press corps basically
that releases all the official pictures
of them so so much of it is based in
looks and then he made one little silly
comment but uh I think it hurts feminism
I agree with you 100% I think that when
you take situations like for instance
Seth MacFarlane at the Oscars and you
say that Seth MacFarlane is sexist that
belittled actual cases of sexism that is
not a case of sexism and I think that
this is another example of that he
couldn't have complimented her in a
better way he talked about all of her
accomplishments he really emphasized
that and then in the very end he said
she's good-looking yeah big deal Jimmy
you're right she's very pretty much okay
bonobos comm is the official outfitter
of the Reuben report enter code TRR to
zero for 20% off your first purchase